Hallo Leute, herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von Das Podcast UFO, dpu, daspodcastufo.de.
Mein Name ist Stefan Tietz, ich bin schon mal hier.
Ich habe oft schon davon geträumt, mal nur mit euch alleine zu sein für so eine kleine, ganz intime Folge, wo man mal nicht unterbrochen wird.
Hey, hey Florentin. Hi, sorry. Hey, ich habe gerade, also.
Hast du an der Fall das? Ne, ich habe ein bisschen angefangen, habe schon bei uns vorgestellt.
Hi, das ist Florentin, von dem ich ihm erzählt habe.
Hi, hallo, das ist das Podcast-Ufo mit Stefan Tatzel-Matzel. Wir sind es schon, und Florentin Willorek. Ich war gerade noch mein, ich musste gerade noch meinen Shaker sauber machen. Stimmt. Stefan und ich, für alle, die es nicht wissen, die gerade erst angeschaltet haben, ihren Podcast-Empfänger, Stefan und ich leben am, ich sag mal, am fortschrittlichen Spektrum des Menschheitsbegriffes. Hier in diesen vier Wänden wird ein neuer Mensch geschaffen, der verzichtet auf Nahrung, auf jede Form von, naja, Genuss. Nee, wir kippen uns seit ein paar Wochen nur noch, naja, als Fehlkauf verteufelt, als beste Erfindung aller Zeiten erkannt?
Hjul.
Hjul. Schreibt man Hjul nur mit H. Und
das ist das erste Problem. Also marketingtechnisch,
man weiß nicht genau, wie man das aussprechen soll.
Aber geil, also man muss nicht mehr essen, das ist ein Nahrungsersatz.
Ich habe gesagt, also ich will
nicht abends da sitzen und mir eine halbe Stunde
lang was zu essen machen. Nein, wo ich auch andere
Sachen, wo ich mir eine schöne Symphonie von
Rachmaninoff reinziehen kann. Nein,
und deswegen habe ich gesagt, ich esse nicht mehr, ich mache keine Zeit mehr für Essen, auch in der Pause hier, nicht mehr so einen Quatsch beim Lidl nebenan holen, nein, einfach nur mal dieses Pulver, ein bisschen mit Wasser anreichern. Genau, es ist so ein Pulver, das man im Wasser in so einem Shaker schickt, das Problem ist halt, ja, ich weiß, aber das ist auch die Krux des Ganzen, weil das Ganze natürlich an diesem Objekt, ich glaube, an wenig Objekten hängt so viel Verachtung und Hass wie an einem Proteinshake, Shaker.
Ich glaube, jemanden, der mit dem in der Hand erwischt wird, also stell dir vor, du fährst in der U-Bahn und du hast zehn verschiedene Gegenstände in der Hand. Welcher Gegenständ macht dich am unsympathischsten? Und ich glaube, ganz weit oben in den Top drei, wenn nicht sogar auf Top eins, ist der Protein Shake Shaker, wo noch so irgendwie so, wo noch so eine athletische Frau, die so die Muskeln anspannt abgebildet ist. Wo jeder sagt, okay, von allen Leuten, Minister der U-Bahn anfängt zu brennen, wer als erstes als Löschversuche versucht wird, ins Feuer zu werfen, ist der Spacco da hinten, der denkt, er wird jetzt irgendwie grossen Muskeln aufbau betreiben, weil sich so ein Zeug reinigt. Leute, die sich so Schuhe an den Rucksack machen, wo ich mir denke, oh mein Gott, du hast doch Schuhe an, das muss doch reichen, man kommt doch mit ein paar Schuhe über den Tag, offensichtlich nicht, oder Leute, ältere Männer mit so einem kleinen Stofftier, was offensichtlich dem Kind gehört, finde ich, ist mir immer so ein Suspekt. Das stimmt, oder Vaporizer natürlich, die sind halt-Vaporizer, wo man auch so direkt Trottel, das sind einfach so evolutionäre Marken. Wenn du rauchst, bist du wenigstens cool. Aber ich finde, Vaporizer nimmt alles, was Rauchen noch gut macht, auch noch weg. Ich glaube, wir haben einen neuen Level der Evolution erreicht. Weil Evolution ist ja, das Prinzip von Evolution ist ja sehr simpel. Schlechte Ideen sterben aus und die Guten bleiben übrig. Ich habe das Gefühl, momentan haben wir das so ein bisschen in 180 Grad gedreht.
Ich habe das Gefühl, die schlechten Ideen nehmen überhand. Kann gut sein. Aber interessant zu sehen, was das mit der Menschheit anstellt, wenn plötzlich nur noch die schlechten Ideen übrig bleiben. Sowas wie, das Problem ist, das ist halt kein, das was wir uns da reinkippen jeden Tag in unsere Münderlöcher, ist kein Proteinshake in dem Sinne so Muskelaufbau, so wie man es kennt, sondern die Idee ist halt, da sind alle Nährstoffe drin, die man braucht in der perfekten Verhältnis. Da ist genau viel Fett, Kohlenhydrate, Eiweiss, genauso viel alle Vitamine, alles was du brauchst ist da drin. Du kannst, das ist halt so Astronautennahrung, da ist alles drin, was du brauchst, möglichst einfach. Aber wenn du allein schon diesen Shaker shakest, du kommst dir vor wie der letzte Spack. Ich hab die ganze Zeit gesagt, sowas mach ich nie, sowas mach ich nie, dann stand da so drin, wie die Astronauten, und ich hab's gekauft. Instant gekauft. Das sind so Sätze, die haben mich sofort Leute im Kasten. Nee, das ist ein bisschen, also wenn es was gäbe, wo man einfach so eine Infusion mit sich rumtragen müsste, wo man die ganze Zeit so, weil auch das, ich will auch diese fünf Minuten Shaken nicht mehr auf mich nehmen, eigentlich,
das ist mir auch noch zu viel. Also wenn ich
dann einfach so intravenös
mir so einen Spritz immer geben müsste, das finde ich cool,
einfach so reinballern, einmal so
einen Shake und dann bin ich gut.
Das wäre eigentlich noch besser ein bisschen.
Ich habe aber auch, also
man kann sich nur davon ernähren,
wenn man möchte, da ist alles drin, was man braucht, aber, da habe ich auch mal gehört, da hat sich irgendjemand versucht, nur von Bier zu ernähren, weil ja Bier auch so eine Art, man sagt ja flüssiges Brot, was da dran ist, weiß ich nicht. Ist Wasser isotonisch? Aber dann kam raus, du weißt doch nicht mehr, was isotonisch bedeutet. Sind Bücher isotonisch? Ist das isotonisch? Ich glaube, alles ist isotonisch auf eine gewisse Art. Und bei dem Experiment kam raus, der Typ ist gestorben, und da hieß es, ja, Bier hat an sich schon alles, was man braucht, außer Salz. Und der ist an Salzmangel gestorben. Und deswegen tatsächlich, aber ich habe mir echt gefragt, also du kriegst gerade eine Mate, wie viele Kalorien hat die, guck mal drauf, pro 100 Gramm? Zu viel wahrscheinlich. Ne, 26.
26 Kalorien. So, aber würdest du dich irgendwann satt fühlen? Weil Mate hat ja Kalorien und ob du jetzt, weil das ist ja Zucker, Zucker ist ja Kulintrat, das ist dasselbe wie Brot, blöd gesagt. Aber Brot macht dich mega satt, aber Zucker nicht so. Bist du von diesen 26 Kalorien in der, ja, so einer, was ist hier, 0,5 Liter Mate satt bist, glaube ich, bist du an Herzrasen gestorben.
Aber ich glaube, das ist prinzipiell ja. Guck mal, 26, dann hat eine Flasche, hat dann 130 Kalorien. So, das ist so wie ein Brötchen, so ein halbes Brötchen vielleicht. Ja. Ein Brötchen. Du hast so ganz merkwürdige Kalorientabellen in deinen Gagdokumenten. Mittlerweile sind es keine Gagdokumente mehr, sondern so abgeschriebene Kalorientabellen. So alles ist es mittlerweile, auch falls ihr euch wundert, warum keine Tweets mehr raushaut. Wenn Tweets, also die Tweets, die jetzt kommen könnten, die wollt ihr auch gar nicht lesen. Das wäre einfach so, Leute, Achtung, Brötchen haben mittlerweile 130 Kalorien. So ein Tweet wäre das mittlerweile. Ich finde... Verbraucherhinweise. Verbraucherhinweis Florentin.
Es ist so, ich finde, das
Konzept von Persönlichkeit ist
überbewertet. Ich finde, man kann
wild seine Persönlichkeit
wechseln. Man kann jetzt sagen,
ach, jetzt bin ich plötzlich so ein Fitnessfreak
und so, und ich glaube, das Einzige, was einen davon
hindert, Persönlichkeit wechseln,
ist Scham.
Sind die Leute, die die in anderen Phasen auch schon mitbekommen haben. Wenn ich sage plötzlich, ich bin jetzt ein professioneller Jogger, dann sagen die Leute, aber wenn ich in die Uni gehe, wo ich dann neu bin plötzlich, und sage, ich bin ein professioneller Jogger, sagen die Leute prinzipiell erstmal, ja, ist klar, hi, ich bin übrigens Marco, schön dich kennenzulernen. Ja, das stimmt, aber wir sind ja immer in unserem Autorenraum und ich sag mal, da sind wir jetzt innerhalb der Firma, würde ich vielleicht schon so eher exzentrische Charaktere, die sowas auch einfach gerne mal weglachen. Was? Und das ist eigentlich üblich, dass man sich... Witz, was sind wir? Exzentrisch? Das ist auch üblich, dass man sich über die... Ja, Florian, wie meint ihr, wir wären exzentrisch. Das stimmt nicht, Stefan zwei.
Das ist auch so, dass man sich über die Schwächen der anderen lustig macht und so. Aber heute waren wir mal Essen mit mehreren aus der Firma. Und dann saß ich neben einem. Ja, ganz kurz, während ich allein in meinem Autorenraum meinen Joule getrunken habe. Und du, plötzlich sagst du nach einem Tag zweiter Diät, sagst du, nö, ich gehe jetzt mal schön Burger fressen mit den ganzen Leuten. Darauf wollte ich da vorhin aus. Man kann allein von Huel überleben, aber meine einzige Angst ist, dass wenn ich jetzt nur noch Huel, also nur noch Flüssignahrung trinke, dass dann meine Zähne degenerieren. Die Zähne sozusagen so wie so Knorpel werden, die man so auch biegen kann. Ja, das ist das so auflösen, weil der Körper sagt so, er braucht keine Zähne. Nee, so schnell er reagiert ist aber glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, alles, was du nicht mehr benutzt, wird abgebaut. Ich dachte eine Zeit lang, ich wäre so ein Supermensch 2.0, weil ich hatte sehr lange keine Weisheitszähne, haben sich nicht gebildet. Da dachte ich mir, ja, mein Körper weiß Bescheid, mein Körper weiß, die braucht man nicht mehr. Hat das Memo bekommen. Hat er schon so abgesondert. Und wahrscheinlich ist mein Steißbein auch wesentlich verkürzt, weil ich schon ein Supermensch bin. Stellt sich raus, hat sich herausgestellt, extrem krass verstümmelte Weisheitszählende, die sehr spät jetzt erst nach oben kommen und dann massiv viele Nerven mit sich ziehen in den Tod. Aber hast du das schon rausgezogen? Nee, wird noch ein Riesenproblem. Im kommenden Jahr, schätze ich, wird das ein Riesenproblem.
Aber das jetzt, also
dieses Röntgen-Ding
war so ein Mittelfinger, der sich so
aus dem, so ein Mittelfingerförmiges
Gebilde, was sich so rausschiebt. Das ist so
ganz unangenehm. Aber das ist jetzt evolutionär ein echtes
Problem, weil wir werden die Weisheitshände
nicht mehr los, weil wir so gut darin sind,
dass wir dann irgendwie supergut betäuben können und die
rausoperieren können und so. Ja, meine grosse These, dass wir die Evolution getötet haben an uns, dass wir nicht besser werden können, weil wir halt zu gut sind für die Evolution. Ich habe Evolution eh noch nicht so hundertprozentig verstanden. Falls ihr der Evolution Storyline schon seit Folge 12 folgt, wisst ihr das bereits? Weil zum Beispiel Augenbrauen, man sagt ja, man hat Augenbrauen, damit einem Schweiss nicht in die Augen läuft.
Aber das... Nee, das ist, wenn man, ich weiß nicht, Schwimmbad. Oder damit man die Emotionen besser... Damit man im Schwimmbad mehr Grip hat, mehr Aerodynamik. Oder damit man Emotionen auf größere Distanz übertragen kann, so... Oh, da ist jemand interessiert, da ganz hinten, damit Bon Jovi auf der Bühne sehen kann, oh, da hinten interessiert sich gerade jemand von dem Song. Der ist skeptisch, er ist so in der Savanne mit so einer Fernluke und dann so guckt, so, hm, ist der skeptisch. Hitler ist gerade wütend, so die beiden Augenbrauen so einfach so zu zwei. Ja, aber damit das funktioniert, müssen ja alle Menschen, die keine Augenbrauen hatten, so massive Probleme mit Schweiß in den Augen hatten, dass sie deswegen ausstehen. Oder die Leute so angewidert waren, dass sie nicht von denen folgt gepflanzt haben. Ja, oder halt Handtücher sich einfach Schweiß abtrocknen. Nee. Warum wachsen auch Frauen eigentlich nicht diese Nadelbäusche, diese, jetzt fällt mir leider für den Gag das Wort nicht ein, diese Dinger, wenn man, wenn Frauen nähen, oh ganz, ich muss ganz weit rausholen, also, wenn Frauen nähen, haben doch manchmal dieses, ja, so einen Halbmond und das, ich nenne es mal Poffel, Poffel, und da kann man so Nadel reinstechen und so, warum merkt der Körper nicht, gut, ihr wisst glaube ich, worauf ich hinaus wollte, ich gebe weiter an Florentin. Also nur so viel, es ist ein bisschen verwirrend, aber das sind die ursprünglich von Huel. Ich glaube, das tut uns nicht gut. Wir werden langsam darauf umsteigen, weil... Ich war am Wochenende auch im Kino, und mir davor habe ich drei Tage lang dieses Zeug genommen. Und dann habe ich Ghost in the Shell gesehen, und das war teilweise ein sehr bunter Film. Da war mir die Helligkeit aber auch zu viel, und dann dachte ich mir auch kurz, ist das überhaupt so gut? Dann habe ich auch Sternchen gesehen, da musste ich mir die Augen zumachen, und dann waren ... Ich glaube, der Film war schwarz-weiss, und mein Körper die ganze Zeit diese Farben. Das war ganz komisch, auch dieses ... Es war alles so hell, und ich führe das aufs Jewel zurück. Ich habe zu viel davon gegessen in der letzten Zeit zeit glaube ich das ist auch nicht gut ich habe auch stefan ist ja als vielkauf stefan bekannt und aber irgendwie also ich mache es mittlerweile so wie so ein kanarienvogel in so einem bergwerk den man so vorschickt und wenn der überlebt dann geht man da auch hin so mache ich stefan ich lasse stefan erst mal sachen kaufen und dann wenn das irgendwie halbwegs funktioniert so wie mit dem zeug ich es mir auch. Aber ich glaube, ich bin mittlerweile ein bisschen zu sehr in deinen Bann geraten. Ich glaube, ich übertreibe es ein bisschen. Ja, ja. Du nimmst auch mittlerweile, wenn der Kanarienvogel so halbtot in der Ecke liegt, sagst du, ja komm, was soll denn der Geist? Der ist müde, der ist, der schläft nur, komm, ich hole mir dieses Zeug auch. Aber wer ist auf die Idee gekommen mit diesem Kanarienvogel? Ist es ein Kanarienvogel oder ist es nicht einfach irgendeine Meise? Nein, nee. Wie sagt man, Habicht? Nee, Kanarienvogel ist doch so ein Gelber. Halt halt wie dieser Tweety. Was, in deinem Kopf ist Habicht direkt neben dem Kanarienvogel. Ist es Habicht? Nee, von den Looney Tunes, der Gelbe, Tweety, der ist doch ein Kanarienvogel. Bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Was sind denn Kanarien eigentlich? Kanaren. Das ist wie so eine Krankheit. Oh, ich hab die Kanaren. Ja, ich... Ihr merkt schon, wir haben von wenig Ahnung. Außer, ja, keine Ahnung, keine Überleitung mehr eingefallen. Aber mir ist noch nicht angefallen, du hast ganz am Anfang mal irgendwann im Podcast von diesem Fahrradfahrer, Fahrradverkäufer erzählt und der, der dich nur kennengelernt hat in den selbstersten Situationen, wo du Fahrrad kaufen wolltest und halt immer umgefallen bist damit. Dieser eine Mensch, der dich immer dann sieht, wenn du es am wenigsten willst, dass sich überhaupt jemanden sieht und der dich halt nur so kennt.
Mir ist aufgefallen, ich habe auch so einen Menschen in meinem Leben, und zwar ist es der Heizungsmann.
So, der
kommt manchmal, und dann hängt für Monate lang
hängt so eine Excel-Tabelle im Hausflur rum,
man muss sich eintragen, wann der denn kommen soll.
Der langweiligste Superheld der Welt. So, und dann hängt
die aber ewig da, und ich bin der Erste, der sich
einträgt, weil ich der Einzige bin, der mir so
voll auffällt, dass er was anderes im Hausflur ist,
und dann schreibe ich mich da immer rein,
und dann vergesse ich aber immer, weil ich
nehme dann auch immer einen Termin vor der Arbeit, weil das ist der einzige Termin, an dem ich kann, weil so spät nach der Arbeit kommen die halt auch nicht mehr, Und dann, wenn man das nicht mehr, wenn man das nicht mehr, wenn man das nicht mehr, wenn man das nicht mehr, wenn man das nicht mehr, wenn man das nicht mehr, ich muss für den, glaube ich, der langsamste Mensch sein der Welt, weil der weckt mich dann immer und dann stehe ich immer so halb neigt dann vor ihm und dann sagt er immer, ja, Herr Thietze, hier ist die Rechnung.
Und ich liess dann immer noch so auf dem, weil man kann sich ja nicht wieder hinlegen, wenn er dann da ist.
Der ist ja dann eine halbe Stunde lang in der Wohnung.
Ja.
Und dann kann man sich nicht wieder hinlegen.
Man hat aber auch nichts anderes zu tun, weil man ist vor der Arbeit, man macht da halt auch nichts.
Und das, was man machen würde, würde man da machen, wo er jetzt ist, im Bad.
Also bin ich dann immer, setze ich mich dann immer aufs Bett und warte halt, bis er wieder geht, aber schlafe da wieder so halb ein und dann, Herr Tietze, keine Reaktion, Herr Tietze, keine Reaktion, dann kommt er so halb ins Schlafzimmer, Herr Tietze, die Rechnung. Was? Und dann er halt so der langsamste Mensch der Welt. Was hält er mich für einen Trottel? Ich reagiere ja auch halt nicht, wenn man so morgens noch so in Halbschlaf ist. Dann macht macht man auch so komische Dinge, dann mache ich immer, mache ich Kaffee, was ich morgens auch nicht mache.
Und so halt so Dinge, die man halt dann macht, so Übersprungshandlung mässig. Und trage so Dinge von A nach B und so Zettel, die auf dem Schreibtisch liegen, trage ich einfach woanders hin, damit er denkt, ich habe gerade ein Leben und setze mich nicht einfach wieder aufs Bett. So, das ist ein ganz komisches Verhältnis, glaube ich, was wir haben. Ja, bei mir ist es auch so, bei meinen Mitbewohnern, die, es ist immer so, manchmal kommen die in mein Zimmer oder klopfen oder wollen so, deine Wäsche ist fertig oder irgendwie sowas, ganz kleine Sachen. Waschen für dich. Solche Sachen. Und wirklich, das ist jetzt vielleicht sechs Mal vorgekommen und wirklich jedes Mal habe ich mir zufälligerweise gerade ein Gute Arbeit Originals Video angeguckt. Ach. Von mir selbst. So, und dann kommen und sehen und die müssen auch denken, nichts anderes, was ich mache, den ganzen Tag ist mich selbst im Internet anschauen. Und Post von Wikipedia bekommen. Ja, und manchmal lache ich auch sehr laut. Die müssen denken, ich gehe auf die Arbeit, drehe da Sachen und gehe nach Hause und schaue mir dann konstant die Sachen immer wieder an und gehe zur Arbeit. Das sind Perpetuum mobile, wo ich wo ich so hin und her, so hin und her gehe. Also eine Selbstbeweihräucherung einfach. Ja. Finde ich nicht schlecht. Ich habe gerade überlegt, wo du gesagt hast, dass die Wäsche ist fertig, Florentin, dass die Dinge für dich machen, dass du die einfach so degradiert hast. Und dann ist mir aufgefallen, in manchen MMORPGs hat man ja so Gefährten, die man dann losschicken kann, Dinge machen. Ja, ich habe da immer ein schlechtes Gewissen. Ja, aber ich wollte gerade sagen, was hat man denn für ein Verhältnis zu denen eigentlich? Man macht nie was für die, nie. Doch am Anfang rettet man die vielleicht einmal, deswegen hat man die dann als Gefährten. Das ist auch so ein Ding. So und dann rettet man die und so, ah, du hast mein Leben gerettet und dann so, ja, schleif mal 2000 Edelsteine für mich. So, okay. Den Rest deines Lebens lang schleifst du jetzt für mich Edelsteine, okay, damit du besser bist darin. Und nur darin. Und die müssen sich auch irgendwie denken, so, wäre ich da einfach gestorben? Und jetzt belebe ich hier in so einer Sklaverei und muss für den Typen irgendwie so, brat mir hundert Hasenfilets. Aber dein Leben lang auch noch, das ist ein Eintask, weil du musst darin besser werden. Ich will dich darin twizelisieren. Ja, ja. Das ist eine ganz komische Welt. Ich dachte mir auch so, wenn du bei Pokémon aufwächst, in der Pokémon-Welt, aber dann in so einer, halt nicht in einem Startergebiet aufwächst als Kind, sondern plötzlich in so einem Advanced, neben der Liga, Endliga. Wie heißt die nochmal? Pokeliga. Okay, das kann man liegen. Kurz vergessen. Bin ich gerade nicht aufgekommen. Wie heißt die Währung nochmal? Pokedollar. Alles klar. Wie heißen die kleinen Tierchen? Digimon. Und dann wächst du ganz am Ende auf und hast dann von deiner Mutter zum ersten Mal so ein Startup-Pokemon bekommen, so ein Level drei und dann gehst du ins Krohe Gras und dann ist da so ein Level hundert Mewtwo und mach dich einfach fertig. Das stimmt, wenn du nicht gerade in der Nähe von Alabastia wohnst, hast du echt verschissen. Du bist instant tot. So einfach überall so wilde Ibitax, die sich mit Level 1000 angreifen. Ja, vor allem, ich dachte immer, es ist immer so, dass alle Kinder Pokémon kriegen, aber ja nur die von Professor Eich, der gibt ja ein erstes Pokémon und alle anderen Kinder wachsen normal auf und werden nie Poketrainer. Das ist auch uncool, wenn du in so einer Alibastia versackst.
So auch einfach.
Esch.
Oh ne.
Nicht so wie, aber das ist doch mega uncool.
Du musst echt aufpassen, wo du aufwächst.
In der Pokelong-Mon-Welt, ja.
Wo glaubst du, wo sind wir gerade?
Sind wir in so einer Low-Level-Welt oder sind wir gerade schon im krassen Gebiet? Stimmt, die Frage ist, sind wir NSCs oder SCs? Ja, das stimmt. Und wer ist der SC in unserer Welt? So, wir sind in einer Matrix, die nur für eine einzige Person geschaffen wurde. Aber wer ist das? Wir sind nur im Hintergrund. Und bereiten wir uns gerade nur auf dem Moment vor, dass wir den mal treffen. Oder vielleicht ist so eine GTA-Welt und irgendjemand fährt gerade mit einem Auto durch die Gegend und fährt Passanten um und hört im Radio unseren Podcast. So dass wir nur einer von diesen Radiosendern sind, für die so eine GTA-Welt. Auf die man manchmal bei Ausversehen kommt, weil man weiß, wo die Bremse ist. Und sich dann vergisst, wie man den Radiosender umschaltet. Und wer anbleibt. Der Rest des Spiels. Aber er nervt. Also latent nervig einfach. Ja, ja. Was hast du mal gehört für einen Radiosender? Ah, ich Ich habe nie GTA gespielt. Wave 103 ist der beste Radiosender jemals in einem Videospiel von Vice City. Wave 104 ist so ein guter. Ich spiele Videospiele per se mit Musik aus und eigener Musik. Macht mir nicht, Story ist wichtig. Die Worten interessiert mich nicht. Ich will ballern. Ich will schön die Leute wegballern. Ballern, mal den Fuss. Ich war der Uncoolste, ich habe ja nicht mal GTA gespielt, sondern True Crime, Streets of LA, was die Gamecube-Variante von GTA war, weil auf der Gamecube, die ich hatte, gab es kein GTA und dann habe True Crime gespielt, wo man halt einen Polizisten gespielt hat, aber auch halt so Open-World-mässig durch die Gegend fahren konnte. Aber es war ganz geil, du konntest dann auch so allen Leuten irgendwie die Autos abnehmen und dann wirst du durch die Stadt gefahren und dann waren so kleine Verbrechen, die du dann aufklären konntest und so und das war schon ganz geil. Ich finde diese Faszination Open-World-Game so interessant, weil hey, draußen vor dem Fenster ist das beste Open-World-Game, das most advanced Open-World-Game, aber man ist halt uncool. Man ist halt nicht Nico Bellic, sondern man ist halt Stefan Maserfucking-Tietz. Aber das Tolle an der Open-World und einem Videospiel ist, du weißt, dass sie nicht perfekt ist. So, du bist ja deine Welt gewohnt und du weißt, sie ist perfekt. Die Physik-Engine ist perfekt, es ist alles gut, jeder Raum ist an mir. Man selbst ist noch nicht perfekt. Aber in der Physikwelt von so einem Spiel habe ich, das Erste, was man macht, ist, man nimmt erstmal ein Auto und fährt erstmal so lange geradeaus, bis man nicht mehr weiterkommt. So, einfach wo sind die Ecken der Realität? Das ist so dieser, das ist, glaube ich, so der Entdeckerdrang, den du in deiner Welt nicht unterbauen kannst, weil alles wurde schon entdeckt. So, du läufst so, oh, ich habe hier in Köln einen neuen Landstrich gefunden, nope. So, aber da kannst du neu, und dann habe ich auch immer geguckt, so, kann ich mich so in die Häuser reinkeilen, dass mich da irgendwie die Gegner nicht mehr treffen und ich dann alle abschießen kann, die können mich aber nicht mehr treffen. Wenn ich so gebacht bin. Genau, wo ich mich so reingebackt habe oder sowas, ja, deswegen wo jetzt erst bei Donkey Kong 64, nee, ich glaube es war Donkey Kong 64, wurde jetzt erst vor einem Jahr irgendwie so eine Banane gefunden, die davor noch nie jemand gefunden hat. Irgendwie so eine goldene Banane, und dann konnte man immer so abschliessen mit, oder irgendwie sowas, ich vereinfache jetzt, mit goldenen Bananen und dann hat aber irgendjemand mal sich den Code angeguckt, wo man irgendwie immer zu allen Gegenständen springen kann und dann war, ist der irgendwo hingesprungen, wusste er nicht, hä, was ist das denn? Dann ist er irgendwie so unter so einem Laubhaufen, wo niemand jeweils draufgekommen ist, war noch eine goldene Banane. Aber er ist auch nicht draufgekommen, indem er gespielt hat, sondern auch nur gespielt hat. Hat es durch den Code. Aber es hat nie, in den gesamten Jahren Donkey Kong, nie jemand draufgekommen, dass diese goldene Banane unter dem Laubhaufen ist. Also es gibt vielleicht da noch Spiele draußen, wo unerkannte Dinge sind. Aber ich war nie so gut. Warst du gut in solchen Spielen, so ein Tetris und sowas? Ich habe mich immer sehr gut gefühlt, aber dann habe ich mal in anderen Spielen gesehen und dann dachte ich mir, ups, okay, das lasse ich lieber auch mal
sein, genau wie Fussballtraining.
In wenigen Spielen
habe ich mich intensiv damit, in WoW
gibt es auch wahnsinnig viele versteckte Sachen, wo dann irgendwelche
ich sich immer zur gleichen Tageszeit
sich irgendwelche Kinder irgendwo versammeln
und dann fangen die an zu singen und dann laufen
die irgendwo hin und dann werden da ganz viele
Leichen gefunden und so und dann
das sagt dir niemand, das checkst du nicht.
Und dann denkst du dir so, okay, creepy, krass, oder vielleicht habe ich es mir auch nur
geträumt. Das war deine Vergangenheit, die du
gerade irgendwie so in die Ecke wenn es
des Mines wegsperrst. Kann auch sein.
Aus
Fehlkaufsteffern wird jetzt eine
advancede Version, weil ich will diese Person ja hinter
mitlassen, das wisst ihr alle, diese Person da nervt,
das ist so eine Klette. Ich
gehe jetzt zu einer neuen Persona über,
die Person, die
Fehlkäufe verkauft.
Ah, Profitstefan.
Für mehr Geld. Ja.
Ich bin Katschingstefan.
Meine Tesla-Aktie ist eh durch die Decke gegangen.
Müssen wir nicht drüber reden. Mega.
Und jetzt auch noch,
fange ich mit Ebay an, ich werde zum
Powerseller und verkaufe jetzt, ich habe so eine Workstation gehabt, wo man halt so Beats mitmachen konnte, so einen Drumcomputer. Moment, ganz kurz drauf eingehen, weil, nein, aber ganz kurz, sorry, aber von allen, also wir wissen, dass du ein Instrument der Freund bist und dass du eine Posaune bei dir rumhängen hast, aber jeder kennt ja, jeder kennt ja diese Geräte, aber jeder kennt ja diese Geräte, wo so einfach so Kacheln drauf sind. Die sehen aus wie so ein großer Nicer Dicer, wo dann auch so Sachen leuchten und dann drückt man da so drauf und dann so ich, ich, ich, ich, ich. Und dann kann man da so als DJ so krasse Sachen machen, so Sample so und dann irgendwie. Und das ist wirklich das Uncoolste, was es gibt auf der Welt. Klar, es gibt so geile Videos von Leuten, die das mega cool können und dann so Beats machen und so, aber sich das zu kaufen und nie zu benutzen ist so... Mega uncool. Ich glaube, es gibt manche Gegenstände, sind allein nur deswegen rentabel, weil sie von Leuten gekauft werden, die sie einfach nur aus Prestige kaufen, aber nie benutzen. Ich wollte das wirklich benutzen, weil das fand ich cool. Ja, klar, natürlich wolltest du es benutzen, ja klar. Natürlich habe ich es klar. Aber ich glaube, die gesamte Musikindustrie lebt davon, dass Leute denken, ah geil, jetzt ein cooler E-Bass, kaufen, nie benutzen, versauern. Aber das war, und ich habe das jetzige Gebot ist schon zehn Euro über den Preis, weil ich bin nicht auch, also ich kann, glaube ich, ganz gut verhandeln und kriege dann auch immer ganz gute Preise und so. Und ich glaube, das habe ich ganz gut raus. Anscheinend ja, weil ich habe alle Gegenstände, die ich bis jetzt wieder reingestellt habe, jetzt schon mehr Gebote. Was hast du denn alles reingestellt? Vielleicht können die Leute mal bei dir ein bisschen shoppen. Ein Jump-Computer, einen alten iMac, den ich nicht mehr benutze. Der kann weg. Was kann noch weg? Alte Kopfhörer habe ich reingestellt. So ein paar Dinge. Play-Sy 3 natürlich. Schaut mal bei Ebay, vielleicht kann man dem Puffopedia-Eintrag von Stefan Titzer noch einen Ebay-Accounts. Aber die Bilder, die mittlerweile auf der Puffopedia sind, die Puffopedia ist komplett eskaliert. Wir dachten, es ist so ein kleines Fun-Projekt, aber die graben da Sachen aus. Holy shit, Alter. Da sind Bilder von mir drin, die habe ich noch nie in meinem Leben. Dieses Abiball-Foto, was da drin ist, ist erstens ein bisschen diffamierend. Sieht aus wie so ein Paparazzi-Foto, was von so einem Promi gemacht wurde, der irgendwie beim Fremdgehen erwischt wird. Also erstens, das Foto habe ich noch nie von mir gesehen, nirgendwo. Ich habe auch Fotos von mir gefunden von einer Abi-Verleihung, wo ich mir dachte, ich habe damals die Fotos von dem Fotografen, der die Abi-Verleihung fotografiert hat, persönlich geschickt bekommen. Die sind nirgendwo öffentlich. Ja, das ist interessant. Und trotzdem, also richtig krass. Wo wir gerade bei der Posaune waren, ich habe neulich mal eine Aufnahme gefunden, ich will euch auch mal ein bisschen zeigen, wie ich mitmache, also wie ich auch lerne, dazulerne, ob ich langsam besser werde an der Posaune. Und ich habe den Herr der Ringe-Soundtrack für mich entdeckt, um darauf ein bisschen rumzuspielen. Da können wir auch gleich darüber reden. Und es ist echt interessant, ihr müsst mal darauf achten,
ob ihr raushört, wann ich anfange mitzuspielen.
Das ist aus dem zweiten Film von der Ringe,
Widers of Rohan ist es, glaube ich.
Hört mal rein, vielleicht ist es ein bisschen,
vielleicht hört ihr nicht genau, wann ich reinkomme,
weil ich bin halt schon sehr gut,
und das Orchester, das hört man noch nicht genau,
aber vielleicht achtet mal gut drauf. Das ist schon nicht so schlecht.
Das ist schon echt gut.
Wie viele Jahre Übung waren da dahinter?
Das war ein Monat oder so.
Wow. Manchmal hat man mich dann auf der Aufnahme auch noch Fluchen danach. Oh Scheiße, Alter. Ich glaube, jeder hatte gerade ein wunderschönes Bild vor dem Kopf, wie Stefan, vier Metermann-Titze, mit dem kleinsten Kopf der Welt, hochrot in seiner Küche steht. Ja, aber ich halte mich auf dem Laufenden, wie ich mich da einweg. Aber da frage ich mich wirklich, wie konnten sich Instrumente durchsetzen, bei denen es schon so schwer ist, überhaupt erst Töne hervorzubringen? Die gleiche Tonfolge auf einem Klavier schafft jeder Mensch der Welt mit fünf Minuten. Weil die Tonerzeugung an sich einfacher ist. Ganz einfach, simpel, Ton drücken, dann. Wie konnte sich jemand, er findet die Posaune und denkt sich, okay, nee, lassen wir. Warum hat da jemand überhaupt den Ehrgeiz, so lange, ohne zu wissen, wohin das führt, so lange die Posaune zu spielen, bis es mal schön klappt? Normalerweise Posaune ja auch innerhalb des Orchesters ziemlich uncool sind, weil die spielen ja oft nicht die Melodie, sondern meistens nur so Fanfaren, also im Hintergrund einfach so ein paar rhythmische Sachen. Also der E-Bass, was der E-Bass in der Band ist, ist die Posaune in Gestern. Ja, aber unverzichtbar. Ja, unverzichtbar, auch gut für Stimmung und so. Und Inception, wo wäre Inception heute ohne die Brass-Section. Aber auf der anderen Seite, sowohl Horn als auch Trompete sind erstens besser zu hören und zweitens auch einfach häufiger haben die die cooleren Parts, die coolere Melodie. Posaunen ist eigentlich nicht so. Ich habe mich jetzt halt wegen dieser Slide und dieser Größe und dieser Lautstärke einfach so einen gewissen Appeal gehabt. Ich weiß nicht. Auch Geige ist ja so unglaublich. Schwierig. Bei so Musikvorspielen, ich weiß nicht, ob du lange in der Musikschule warst, aber da jedes Jahr Musikschule
und dann immer haben alle vorgespielt
und es war halt wirklich einfach immer so ein
Weg nach Stalingrad, weil du,
das war ja von Klassen niedrig
bis hoch und die ersten Klassen,
wo du einfach denkst, einfach geh sterben.
Du einfach wirklich, und vor allem wo dann
die Lehrerin hat dann immer am Flügel
die Geigenspielerin und die Lehrerin halt so
schön, und dann kommt Naaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa immer, wie kann jemand, wie können alle gerade nicht Keyboard spielen, weil du hast die Stimmung im Sack, also die Stimmung nach nach fünfzehn Minuten, nach fünfzehn Stunden ist dann halt einfach der drück auf den Knopf und das geht so ein Samba-Beat an und alle schon die Eltern schon wow, er kann das irgendwie so eine seltsame Mut-Armonika-Musik darüber spielen, scheißegal, Samba-Beat macht es einfach, also das Keyboard gewinnt im Automatisch halt, weil es so eine Stimmung macht. Aber das ist auch einfach unfair, weil das Ergebnis ist einfach nicht gleich verteilt. Und ich würde manchmal gerne sagen, so, hey, hallo Leute, ich spiele die Geige, für alle, die keine Ahnung von Musik haben, Geige ist total schwer zu spielen. Das heißt, das, was ihr bei dem Klavier gerade genossen habt, ist bei mir einfach hundertmal so viel Arbeitaufwand. Und das, was ihr jetzt gleich hört, ist viel besser als das, was ihr gerade gut fandet vom fucking Klavier, fick dich Klavier. So, viel Spaß mit zwei Geige. Ja, ich war gerade auch bei Musikgereden, ich war bei einem Herr der Ringe-Konzert. Und zwar war hier Herr der Ringe live ein Konzert, die haben den Film gezeigt in der großen Lancer-Arena, 15.000 Leute waren da, die haben den Film auf der großen Leinwand gezeigt und es war halt eine Version Welcher Film? Herr der Ringe, Teil 1, Gefährten. Und dann war tatsächlich die Musik halt ausgemischt, also da war eine Version ohne Filmmusik und ohne Gesang und so, und dann war davor halt ein riesen, so neunzigköpfiger Chor, neunzigköpfiges Orchester und die haben dann einfach die Musik dazu live gespielt, das war mega beeindruckend, es war unglaublich beeindruckend. Und allein die Anfangsschlacht, das war richtig episch, aber dann kommt es irgendwann zu so einem Moment, ganz am Ende, wo die dann gegen die Orks kämpfen, so die Uruk-Kai sind sie glaube ich dann schon, da kämpfen sie dann am Ende auf so einer Anhöhe. In Amon-Hen, ja. Nein, in Amon-Hen, alles klar, und da kommt dann nicht mehr der volle Chor zum Einsatz, sondern ein Kinderchor, lustigerweise.
Kam aber zur Situation, dass im Hintergrund einfach brutalerweise Orks geköpft wurden.
Und dann einfach so ein Messer in den Hals und dann Blut und Schmatzer und davor einfach so ein Chor von 15 jungen jungen Mädchen, die so singen, mit so einer Dirigentin und einfach so ganz schön singen. Dreht euch auf gar keinen Fall um, Kinder. In dem Hintergrund, einfach Köpfe. Das fand ich so lustig. Aber der ist ja ab zwölf, oder ist er ab sechs? Ja, weil sonst dürften die das ja gar nicht. Die dürften das ja gar nicht. Die dürften das nicht, deswegen haben die auch so Augenbinden.
Aber das war wirklich lustig, dass so ein frommer Mädchen Chorien immer so schön singt.
Und im Hintergrund wird es einfach brutal.
Das finde ich auch so weird, dass teilweise Kinder in Filmen mitspielen, die sie nicht sehen dürfen.
Die spielen in dem Film mit, aber der Film ist ab 18 und dann auch so, kann ich mal kurz sehen, wie ich aussah?
Nein, kann ich mal kurz sehen, ob ich da gut gespielt habe?
Nein, darfst du leider nicht.
Kannst du mir vielleicht sagen, damit ich meinen Charakter besser verstehe, kannst du mir ein bisschen was Backstory geben oder so? Ich meine, warum bringe ich diesen Hasen gerade um? Kann ich den Roman lesen, auf dem es passiert? Nein. Stimmt, es gibt keine Bücher, Altersbeschränkungen, aber Filme schon, das ist schon komisch. Ein Kind darf doch einfach so Stephen King lesen, oder? Wenn jetzt ein Achtjähriger im Buchladen Stephen King kauft. Ich habe auch zu früh Stephen King Bücher gelesen, ich also viel zu früh das ist glaube ich auch ein gründ für vieles aber das war eigentlich also ein cooler abend also das war nicht einfach ein cooles ereignis so also kann man echt mal häufiger machen ich wurde auch erkannt von einem aus dem publikum zwar das war sorry für den moment den ich ein bisschen verkackt habe weil ich hatte eis in der einen hand und mein paar bunni in der anderen hand und dann wolltest du mir die hand Hand geben und zu sprechen, gleichzeitig zu sagen, Entschuldigung, ich kann gerade noch nicht sprechen, weil ich meine Hände voll habe und die muss ich erst mal leeren. Dann war das Portemonnaie bei einer falschen Hand. Für den Moment, dass du dachtest, dass ich nicht mit dir sprechen will, hat das gefragt, störe ich gerade? Ich habe gesagt, nein, nein, nein, Entschuldigung, kurz. Und dann hat es auch 15 Minuten gedauert, bis ich mir mein Pomponente verstaut habe und die Hand geben konnte.
Tut mir leid, aber wenn ihr, also falls ihr mich anspricht und das Gefühl, was ein arrogantes Arschloch, dann denkt vielleicht erstmal an diesen Moment, dass ich vielleicht den Moment einfach selber verkackt habe gerade. Ja, das ist so merkwürdig, wenn Leute dann plötzlich so nervös sind, wenn sie einem persönlich begegnen und dann so, ah, das ist doch der Typ, der immer erzählt, was er für ein absoluter Versager ist. Wow, krass, ich bin aufgeregt, den zu treffen, so obwohl man eigentlich dafür gehört wird, was man für ein Versager ist, was dann immer so merkwürdig ist. Vor allem, wir sind verletzbar für euch, also ihr könnt auch einfach mit so einem, ihr wisst alles über uns, alle unsere Schwachstellen. Ey, ihr seid uns persönlich eins zu eins immer überlegen, sowohl sozial als auch körperlich, als auch coolesmäßig in der echten Welt. Das war auch so, dass ich so gewartet habe an dem Zug und Leute sind so rausgekommen aus dem Zug. Und man hat jemand gesehen, jemand ist so wirklich komplett gelangweilt und ist dann so die Stufen runter und hat sozusagen im letzten Sprung, hat er mich gesehen, erkannt und wirklich in kürzes Eile eine Entscheidung getroffen und ist direkt auf mich zugesprungen und hat mich umarmt. Obwohl am Anfang der Bewegung er noch nicht mal wusste, dass ich da bin und musste einfach reagieren und hat mich umarmt und ich so, Jesus, und dann so, hey, geil, Flut, cool, Beef trägt, ich so, ja, cool, aber man hat gemerkt, er musste jetzt was machen, weil du kannst ja nicht vorbeigehen und dann nochmal so, ihm glaube ich ja doch nicht. Aber du bist ein Knuddeltyp, ne? Du stehst darauf, du liebst es doch. Ich meine, du bist ein Knuddler, kommst du auch immer im Laufe des Tages an. Ich glaube, ich werde lieber umarmt, als so dieses Kumpelhafte auf die Schulter hauen. Das ist, glaube ich, das, also ich glaube, ich... Das ist erniedrigend. Ja, ich glaube, ich lasse mir lieber in den Schritt greifen, als so dieses, äh, Flutti und so, dieses, Alter, ich bin, ich kenne dich nicht so, das ist viel intimer. Auch diese grosse Pranke, die man immer so runterdrückt. Aber das kann mir nicht passieren, weil ich meistens grosser bin. Die meisten Leute kommen mit ihrem Arm nicht auf meine Schulter. Das ist gut, ja, und du bist ja auch körperlich einschüchtern. Die Person war sehr nervös, das hat mich auch nervös gemacht, weil da so eine Gegend hat, die hat mich so hochgeschaukelt, das war so sehr, ihr müsst auch nicht nervös sein. Nein, die können uns immer gerne ansprechen. Ja, besonders Flo und die mit einer Umarmarmung. Was hast du denn demnächst vor für coole Abendveranstaltungen? Du hast bestimmt auch mal demnächst geschönt. Gehst du mal ins Theater? Bei einem Konzert in Köln. Echt? Was für eine Musik? Nee, brauchst du nicht, aber was für eine Musik? Der Barock. Iron Maiden. Schon richtiger in die Fresse Rock, würde ich sagen. Also da wird schon mal wirklich gewackelt mit dem ganzen Körper. Da wird so ein Bierkanister, ein Bierbärchen habe ich geworfen. Auf jeden Fall. Gepogt? Gemoscht? Ich im Pogo-Pit, da bin ich ja wohl der Erste, der da sagt, jau Leute, jetzt aber... Wollen wir pogen? Komm, wir pogen kurz. Ja, nee, ich weiß nicht, was das bedeutet. Nee, bei mir ist es recht ruhig eigentlich. Ich versuche gerade ein bisschen abzunehmen, will auch heute wieder laufen gehen, ich weiß nicht, werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht schaffen. Ja, hab jetzt angefangen, ich hab's geschafft, Windows in Cilind of my Mac, irgendwie hab jetzt Age of Empires mal gespielt. Und ansonsten, ja, ist nicht viel los in meinem Leben. Manchmal hat man auch einfach so eine Phase, wo nicht viel passiert. Und man dann zurückblickt und sagt, ach, es war eigentlich ganz schön. Man merkt ja oft nicht die Phasen, in denen es einem gut geht. Weil dann merkt man plötzlich, oh, ich habe keinen Job mehr, ich habe kein Geld mehr. Oh, war eigentlich ganz toll die Zeit. Aber in der Zeit, in der man ist, dann merkt man es nicht. Die besten Interviewer halten einfach mal zwischendurch ihre Fresse, weil dieses Nicht-Zufrieden-Sein mit einer Antwort ist, glaube ich, am besten artikuliert, indem man sich nicht artikuliert. Wenn einer will, sagt, na, die haben manchmal eine Frage geantwortet und dann hat er wieder die Chance auszuweichen. In dem Moment, wo der einfach verhungern lässt, weil du merkst, die Antwort ist nicht immer eine Frage und man einfach schweigt und dieses, man erwartet noch mehr, dieses nicht zufrieden sein mit der Antwort. Auch so in der Luft so rudern, schaufeln. Dieses okay und jetzt kommt es an, aber jetzt sagst du es doch. Ja, das ist auch mal, Man sollte Leute generell so behandeln, als wären sie gerade kurz davor, den Durchbruch zu machen. Als wären sie gerade vor der Kamera. Als wäre man Aufnahmeleiter und die wären vor der Kamera. Als würde man so ein gewisses Wort, als wäre man der Mathelehrer, der mit der x hoch zwei ist gleich auf vier durch a minus b.
Ja, genau. Und so behandle ich generell Leute, wenn sie irgendwas erzählen.
Also wenn sie kurz vor dem Durchbruch... Ich habe damals eine gewisse Szene, die hängen geblieben ist, damals in meinem deutschen Unterricht.
Welche?
Und er wollte eine Lehre ein Wort von uns haben.
Aber niemand hat es geschafft.
Und alle haben aufgezeigt.
Und niemand wusste das. Und dann haben wir gesagt, wie ist diese Person, um die wir gerade besprechen? Ist sie mutig? Nein. Ist sie gewaltbereit? Nein. Und dann kam ich und haben gesagt, sie ist pragmatisch. Ja! Und es war pragmatisch. Da haben wir es. Pragmatisch. Was war dein stolzester Moment in der Schulzeit? Ja, das war es glaube ich. Das wirklich? Ja, weil eine halbe Stunde lang, lächerlich lang, haben wir dieses Wort gesucht. Und dann habe ich einfach aufgezeigt, war wir die ganze Zeit beschäftigt, habe nebenbei Gamer gespielt, habe ich aufgezeigt, pragmatisch, bam, das war's. Ich möchte auch einfach so, weil mit der Puffopedia im Nacken, möchte ich auch einfach das nochmal in die Geschichtsschreibung der Welt meinen... Das ist uncool jetzt. Ja, dann nicht. Nee, aber es ist uncool, das ist mit der Ansage zu bringen, dass sie das in die Pufopeder schreiben. Nein, man überdenkt ja sein Leben so ein bisschen. Man hat dann, man schaut diese Pufopeder-Seite an, dann denkt sich, okay, das ist mein Leben. Okay, gut. Und das sieht zu den ersten 80 Prozent richtig, richtig düster aus. Und deswegen möchte ich auch, dass also
gerade meine Seite,
konzentriert sich halt stark auf Thema Körpergewicht
und deswegen dachte ich, könnte man dem einfach
ein bisschen was entgegensteuern, indem ich jetzt
einfach sage, der beste, der stolzeste Moment
meiner Schulzeit war im Wirtschaftsunterricht,
als die Lehrerin gefragt hat,
was sind denn Einnahmequellen
des Staates? Und sie hatte schon so eine
Folie auf dem Overhead-Projektor liegen und mit so einem Zettel drauf, so klassisch, und hat dann so Stück für Stück runtergezogen. Er war der erste Lehrer, der das gemacht hat. Ja, aber das war auch immer so problematisch, weil wenn du halt fünf Punkte hast und ein Schüler nennt erst den dritten Punkt, dann muss man halt immer noch so ein Blatt von oben nehmen und dann so runter und dann sagt jemand das fünfte und dann so ja, shit, dann war es ganz schlecht und dann hatte die schon alle fünf richtigen Antworten, halt dieses Steuern, die fünf richtigen Antworten auf den Zettel und dann habe ich gesagt, Geldstrafen. Und dann hat sie gesagt, ja, stimmt. Und dann musste sie im nächsten Punkt auch machen. Und das hatte sie nicht auf ihrem Arbeitsblatt, auf ihrer Folie.
Ja, hast du recht. Hast du recht?
Du hast... Und dann musste sie tatsächlich mit so einem Filzstift noch sechstens Geldstrafen dazu schreiben.
Und danach musste sie erst mal jemanden anrufen. So, hey, hey, hey, verkaufen.
Hey, achte du das auf dem Schirm mit Geldstrafen?
Da musste anscheinend, ach nee, ich glaube, in Bayern musste der gesamte Lehrplan geändert werden, weil ich da noch was hinzugefügt habe, weil da niemand jemals draufgekommen ist, dass der Staat ja Geld einnimmt durch Geldstrafen. Das war das Erste, was mir eingefallen ist. Und tatsächlich, und ich denke mir so, die hat die Folie wahrscheinlich schon in vielen Jahrgängen davor benutzt. Alle dumm, alle dumm die Jahrgänge, nur ich habe dieses Blatt perfekt gemacht. Bei mir ist auch mal was, es gab ein Brainstorming damals in der Grundschule, war das noch, es gab ein Brainstorming zu Strom, Elektrizität. Brainstorming, wer hat Ideen, Wechselstrom, gute Idee, noch weitere Ideen, Ideen. Wir sollten einfach so sammeln, was verbinden wir damit, das war so Sachunterricht sowas. Wie nennen wir das Fach, wo einfach Sonstiges, Mathe, Sport, Rally, Sonstiges. Aber wir wollen jetzt drei Stunden lang Rest, oh nein. Alter, hast du die Resthausaufgaben für Hausie? Hast du die Resthausie für morgen? Rest. Ja, und dann war Sachunterricht halt und es ging um Sachen, nämlich um Elektrizität. Und dann hieß es ja, wer kennt welche Begriffe? Und dann habe ich irgendwann, war das schon alles voll geschrieben, da habe ich aufgezeigt und gesagt, ACDC. Und alle haben gelacht. Und sie so, ja, das ist eine Band. Und alle haben noch mehr gelacht, alle haben noch mehr gelacht und ich war am Boden. Ich wurde zerstört. In der Pause, ich war das Opfer der Pause, er hat eine Band geslacht, wo wir einen Exotät gefunden haben. Dass er aber auch wirklich nicht so clever ist. Am nächsten Tag habe ich dann so ein Englisch-Wörterbuch mitgebracht. Und da stand vorne drin, AC-DC, Gleichstrom, Wechselstrom. Habe es aufs Pult gelegt. Sie hat gesagt, wow, das wusste ich nicht. Gut, Stefan. Und die ganze Klasse, so ein Lichtstrahl ist auf mich gekommen. Und die ganze Strasse hat Halleluja gesungen. Das war ganz schön cool. Und haben die sich nochmal bei dir entschuldigt? Nein, weil wie kleine Arschlochkinder haben sie mich dann dafür gehänselt, dass ich einen Duden mit in die Schule gebracht habe. Dann, andere, gleiche Lehrerin, anderes Fach, nee, war auch Sachunterricht, Biologie war, glaube ich, gezählt auch unter Rest, und da war ein Test, und dann sollten wir die Knochen bestimmen, und dann gab es, dann ist halt die Frage, das sind für ein Schulfach. In der Grundschule. Und dann war halt die Frage, wann die Halswirbel in die Rückenwirbel übergehen. Und dann war das nicht ganz, war das so ein bisschen schwierig eingezeichnet. Und dann habe ich einen Fehlerpunkt bekommen, weil ich das noch als Nackenwirbel bezeichnet habe. Und dann habe ich gesagt, Moment mal, ich glaube aber nicht, dass das stimmt. Dann habe ich zu Hause so ein Lexikon mitgebracht, wo... Der nervigste Schüler der Welt! Das ist Stefan! Aber es ist so ein großes Lexikon, man hat ja auch so einen kleinen Turnister, aber es war so ein lächerlich großer Bildband, den ich dann mitgebracht habe, aufgeschlagen habe. Und dann hat sie uns allen den Punkt gegeben, für Leute, die da noch Nackenwebeling geschrieben haben. Die heutigen Schüler können sich das gar nicht vorstellen. Heute halt so, ja, ich schicke den Link oder wir schauen kurz auf der Wikipedia nach, aber damals musste man noch in seinen Keller und da irgendwie die Ausgrabung dann fertig machen, um dieses große Lexikon einfach mitzubringen.
Ich habe so oft Bücher mit in die Schule gebracht, weil ich bewiesen habe, dass ich mehr weiß.
Ich hatte auch eine Englischlehrerin, wo ich mir wirklich strengweise dachte, ich bin einfach klüger als die, wo dann so ein Vokabeltest und dann war dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, nackt und dann habe ich geschrieben nude und dann hat sie geschrieben, nee, falsch, naked, wo ich mir dann so, äh, sorry, ich bin viel auf Webseiten unterwegs und ich glaube, ich weiß, und ich spreche, die hat dann immer wirklich, das musste das richtige Wort sein, obwohl meins auch gestimmt hat, das habe ich mich sehr mit der angelegt, aber dann auch nicht. Es gab bei uns mal einen Test, wo es hieß, sorry, jetzt wird gerade so abdriften, aber da hieß es dann, was heißt Daily?
Auch völlig so eine Schulaufgabe, wo nur so ein kleiner Zettel ausgeteilt wurde.
Was heißt Daily? Ist das jetzt Mathe oder ist das Physik? Was soll das?
Und es war Englisch und dann sollte man, das war so ein Vokabeltest, Daily.
Und ich beschrieben, ja, es ist ein Art Restaurant, so ein kleines Restaurant halt. Falsch, die Antwort war Delicious. Da dachte ich mir, Moment mal kurz, erst mal ... Bei allem musste man nur das deutsche Wort dazu schreiben. Plötzlich müssen wir eine andere ... Ist das eine Abkürzung gefragt, dann müssen wir nicht das deutsche Wort, sondern das englische Wort finden? Jesus, du hast das Vokabeltest-Game auch offensichtlich auf Level 12 erhoben.
Deli kommt von Delicious?
Ja.
Ich dachte, das war was Indisches.
Das ist eine ganz andere Frage.
Ja, das dachte ich dem Jao.
Ach, scheiße.
Wegen Neu-Delhi, dachte ich.
Ja, eben, ich dachte auch tatsächlich, das ist eine indische Art von Resort.
Ach, ich habe auch keine Ahnung.
Wir haben auch keine Ahnung, aber das ist auch eine dumme Aufgabe.
Es gibt so viele Begriffe, wo man nicht genau weiß, was es ist. So Imbiss. Ja, oder Buch. Oder Bistro. Was ist das? Bistro? Ich habe letztens so ein Kofferwort gesehen und so eine Mischung aus zwei völlig weirden Worten. So wirklich so Bistris oder so Imbiss und Bistro. Warte, beides sind Nonsenswörter und ihr macht da noch ein Nonsenswort draus. Oder irgendwas anderes. Imbiss. Ich glaube, Takeaway und Imbiss. Take bis oder irgendwie so ein... Take a bite. Bullshit. Aber kommt Imbiss denn vom Beissen bis... Ich glaube, das kommt vom lateinischen Imbiss-Tuss oder sowas. Wollen wir bei dieser Comedy-Einrasse, kurz mal wieder zurückfahren, wollen wir kurz drehen? Ja, kurz mal rückwärtsgang, komm rückwärtsgang. Bip, bip, bip. Rest der Folge einfach nur, bip. Der Erste, der das entwickelt hat, dieses Rückwärtsfahren. Ich habe gar nicht an Echolot gedacht. Dieses Piep, Piep, Piep. Gibt es noch U-Boote? Sind U-Boote noch ein Thing? Und haben die immer noch diese Echolote, diese furchtbar nervigen, schlafen die dann auch bei diesem Ton, diesem Ping? Das ist gar keine so dumme Frage, ob U-Boote heute. Danke, es gibt mittlerweile meine Fragen, wie wert ist in dumm, nicht so dumm, mega dumm und dumm, typisch Stefan dumm.
Ich glaube schon, das ist, also gibt es bestimmt noch, aber ob die eine,
hört man nie, man hört immer nur so von Flugzeugträgern irgendwie im nordkoreanischen Gewässer
oder irgendwelche Kampfflugzeuge, aber U-Boote, so die denken sich auch so,
ja Leute, hallo, wir sind schwer zu sehen, aber wir existieren auch noch.
Warum waren die denn mal, da hat man mal gesagt, wow, gute Idee, Wahnsinn, unter Wasser, das sieht niemand kommen, es ist nicht seit der Erfindung des Radars, Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,, von wo man kommt. Es gibt Atomumboote, die haben doch Atomsprengköpfe und so. Ich glaube, die werden mit Atomen betrieben, deswegen heißen die Atomumboote. Ja das auch, aber es gibt auch Atomumbote mit Nuklearraketen, glaube ich.
Nein, ja.
Ich glaube schon.
Heute, die große Halbwissen-Folge.
Ey, diese Kommentare, wo wurde denn immer bekommen, dass wir das nicht genau wissen?
Ja, jemand hat uns erklärt, wie ein Akku funktioniert.
So, gucken wir uns doch mal kurz an, wie ein Akku funktioniert.
Das haben wir schon vorgelesen. Realität. Kommen wir nun zu der nächsten Rubrik. Realität. Fake-Check. Nee. Wir haben noch nie eine Nachricht mehr von uns redigiert, also neu klargestellt. Es gab noch nie eine Klarstellung. Also Max schreibt, wie ein Akku funktioniert. Erstens, Memory-Effekt gibt es nicht mehr, also erst leermachen ist nicht nötig. Zweitens, diese Akkus wollen, also Lithium-Akkus, wollen auf keinen Fall komplett entladen werden. Drittens, diese Akkus wollen auch nicht lange geladen rumliegen. Was wollen sie denn? Das heißt, Handy, Laptop immer an der Ladestation killt die dinger gut also immer auf 80 prozent aufladen dann wieder lehr machen mit so einer akuten antihaltung die dinger ein bisschen angepisst geschrieben so dass diese drecks die wollen nicht geladen werden ist kilt die halt hatte ich auch mal auf ein genervteror. Ich war ja im Callcenter und da haben Leute immer angerufen, weil die haben so eine Mailbox bekommen und dann hat auch immer jemand angerufen so, ja dann habe ich bei dem Drecksding angerufen und dann habe ich meine Scheissnummer eingeladen und die haben mir so, wow, wow, wow, wow, ey, lass uns erst mal auf einer Basis anfangen, aber die hat mir schon jetzt keinen Bock mehr. Nein, weil die zum achten Mal bei dir anrufen, siehe Paypal. Ja, aber die rufen das erste Mal und die sagen schon so, als ob ich will, ja, dann habe ich diese scheiss Schrottgeräte und so. Wovon reden sie denn? Was? Genauso habe ich aber auch gesprochen. So, ja, wir haben ja dieses Pufo.fail, das ist kein Geld mehr und diese Dreckscheiße von dem einen Konto, das ist auf dem anderen Konto und die fucking Handnummer habe ich mich verschrieben und der fünfte, den ich dann angerufen, da musste er auch denken, so wow, was ist denn mit ihm verkehrt eigentlich? Was ist denn unser Paar? Aber wirklich 99% des Problems, die Kunden bei meinem Callcenter haben so einen Callcenter bekommen und eine Nummer. Und dann mussten die dort anrufen und dann die Nummer eintippen. Dann hieß es immer, geben Sie die Nummer jetzt ein, dann mussten wir die eintippen. Und 99% aller Leute, die bei mir angerufen haben, haben die Nummer gesagt, statt einzutippen. Und es war immer so, kann es sein, dass sie die Nummer gesagt haben? Und dann hatte ich teilweise, haben die dann auch auf ihrer Mailbox nochmal die Nummer aufgesprochen. Völlig unnötig, es waren so Kontaktanzeigen gedöhnt, so dass dann Leute, wenn sie da angerufen haben, so, ja, jetzt hören sie die Nachricht von ihrem Liebhaber 56 oder 30 sechse siebzig muss jetzt da hört man das ja hallo jetzt die bianke aber jeder jeder der angerufen hat erst mit 56 oder 30 sommer 70 was glaubst du weil wie das funktioniert und Du Depp einfach. Kurz mal, Anekdoten-Crasher, wenn du so eine Nummer einsprichst, bezweifle ich. Eben, das funktioniert sowieso nicht. Aber der hat es ja nicht mal an der richtigen Stelle überhaupt eingesagt. Also völlig falsch. Erst wenn er seine Nachrichten wieder abhören wollte, hätte er seinen Code eintippen müssen. Aber es ist kompliziert. Aber das verstehe ich auch nicht. Aber es ist komplette Brüche. Manchmal muss man ja dann, wenn Sie eine Störung haben, drücken Sie die zwei. Ja. Und dann drücke ich die zwei. Kann man das alles überspringen, indem man die richtige Nummer eingibt? Oder könnte man nicht mal eine Website geben, wo man diese Endungen vorher schon eingibt? Weil das ganze Gelaber. Meistens kommt dann der Punkt, den man braucht, eh bei Nummer acht. Da muss man davor sieben lang Butsch. Tatsächlich sind es verschiedene Systeme, bei manchen Systemen musst du erst auf den richtigen Kommando warten, bei manchen kannst du schon von Anfang an, das sind die modernen, also alles, was nach 1980 programmiert wurde, da kannst du schon von Anfang an eintippen. Aber im Endeffekt kommst du immer mit dem gelangweilten Typen raus, der gerade wenn dein Anruf kommt, irgendwie sich gerade eine Salami-Brötchen in die Knie schiebt. Das ist auch wie so ein MMORPG, also egal welchen Weg man geht, welche Zahlen man drückt, am Ende ist man bei dem einen Endgegner so, und der hat auch keine Lust auf dich. Aber wie viele Leute haben sich bei dir verabschiedet im Callcenter? Ja, doch einige. Echt jetzt? Ja, ja. Callcenter ist ja zu 80% abwimmeln. Aber wenn ich meine Lösung habe, will ich maximal schnell aus dem Gespräch raus. Das Problem ist, die, also generell beim Kundensupporten, ich glaube, das trifft auch viele zu, die hatten ein ganz spezielles Erlebnis. So, und dann sagen sie, ja, das hat nicht geklappt. Und dann versuchst du dieses Erlebnis zu rekonstruieren, aber das funktioniert nicht. Der sagt so dann, ja, haben sie den in die Nummer eingetippt? Ja, das war sie nicht. Ja, und haben sie das denn gemacht? Ja, schon. Und dann behaupten die halt einfach Dinge, aber du kriegst diesen konkreten Fall, der zu dem Problem geführt hat, nicht mehr rekonstruiert, schlicht. Auch weil Leute nicht zugeben wollen, dass sie einen Fehler gemacht haben. Ja, genau, und die sagen dann so, ja, weiß ich nicht, und haben sie da oder das oder so. Und das heißt, dein Hauptproblem ist, ja, das klappt schon, machen sie es einfach nochmal. Einfach nochmal abwimmeln. Das heißt, du musst immer nur abwimmeln. Und da spielt die Verabschiedung eine große Rolle. Ich glaube, was die Leute wollen,
was die Leute wollen, ist,
also die dürfen keinen Fehler haben und so den einzigen Fehler im System gefunden zu haben,
den es gibt.
Sie wollen dieses eine Montagsmodell haben,
was nicht funktioniert.
Und auch oft die Frage,
ja, aber das hat jetzt nicht geklappt,
hat mich der Anruf trotzdem was gekostet?
Immer nein, natürlich nicht. Klar, natürlich kostet er auch was. Das ist gelogen, angelogen. Immer angelogen, immer einfach gesagt, nein, natürlich nicht. Weil er, wenn er dann sagt so, ja, die Kosten zur Rückerstattung, ja, der Anruf hat 30 Sekunden gedauert, also kriege ich 80 Cent zurück und dann musst du dann einen Scheck ausstellen. Musst du wirklich ausstellen? Ja, natürlich musst du das dann sehen, wenn da irgendwas nicht funktioniert. Dann ist ja massiv illegal vollgangene. klar, das ist alles illegal, das ist ein combater Bullshit. Natürlich, wenn die da anrufen und dein System funktioniert nicht, dann musst du natürlich Geld zahlen. Aber erst mal zu rekonstruieren, ob wirklich das Problem auf deiner Seite lag oder ob die was falsch gemacht haben, ist unmöglich. Das heißt, du musst einfach sagen, nein, das passt schon. Und erst wenn die dann mit ihrer Telefonrechnung nochmal anrufen und sagen, ja, sie hatten ja damals, und dann sagt er, wirklich, nein, natürlich übernehmen wir die Kosten. Aber Callcenter Lügen, wenn die sagen, okay, da muss ich ganz gut mit meinem Vorgesetzten sprechen, bleiben Sie ganz kurz dran, was machen die da wirklich in der Zeit? Gar nichts, überhaupt nichts. Nee, Moment mal. Nö, gar nichts. Ach, du hast den Satz mal gesagt, ich muss kurz mit meinem Vorgesetzten sprechen und dann einfach kurz aufgemutet und dann kurz einfach mal weiter. Ich habe oft einfach aufgelegt. Ja, da lernte ich sie ganz kurz weiter, klick aus. Und dann wenn er nochmal anruft, ach wirklich, ach so, das tut mir leid, ja dann ist er anscheinend gerade momentan noch in einem anderen Call. Ich versuch's doch mal. Ich versuch's doch mal auflegen. Aber auch generell, je unfreundlicher die Leute sind, desto eher, desto länger bist du in der Warteschleife gehalten. Einfach dieses Klassische. Ja, ich frage kurz mal nach. Warteschleife, bin ich 20 Minuten in der Warteschleife gehangen und dann einfach nochmal. Ja, das Problem lag nicht auf unserer Seite. Man will die auch so Weiss zutreiben. Man will die Wütenden, da denkt man, wow, man will die ja so einen Herzinfarkt treiben, oder? Man will dann noch mal ein bisschen so anstacheln, das Schwachen. Du hast die absolute Macht über diese Leute, weil du einfach so, ah, warte, schlau, oder dann hören die irgendeinen schlechten Crap. Boah, das ist wunderbar, du hast die absolute Macht. Cool wäre, anhand der Stimmung des Anrufers zu erkennen, welcher Mitarbeiter am ehesten jetzt zugeschaltet wird, dass man das mal so ein bisschen streut, dass mal jeder ein Angenehm bekommt, dass die Mitarbeiter auch ein bisschen Abwechslung bekommen. Und dann, dass die Stimmung schon erklärt, was für ein Problem vorliegt. So die maximal Genervten sind offensichtlich die, die kein Problem haben und die, die so halb genervt sind, die, okay, können eine Störung vorliegen. Ich glaube, es hat sich auch mal jemand beschwert über mich, aber ich habe generell falsche Namen verwendet, ich habe mich immer als falsche Name vorgestellt und es war mal tatsächlich so, ja, es hat sich jemand vorgestellt, über jemanden Christian. Und dann so, hä, aber Christian
hat doch schon vor drei Monaten gekündigt.
Ja, ganz komisch. Und ich habe immer
Christian gesagt, oder ich weiß nicht genau,
genau wie der Christoph oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung,
der vor kurzer Zeit gekündigt hat, einfach
damit ich dann sagen kann, ja, das war ja der, ah ja, okay,
hat der Scheiße gebaut, aber der hat es gekündigt.
Dem werden jetzt nicht nochmal nach der Kündigung anrufen
und sagen, ja, du hast ja bei einem Anrufer aber
das falsche Teil gesagt. Deswegen einfach
immer.
Ja, aber ich kann
moralisch nicht so ganz...
Hey, Leute, wir müssen mal aufhören,
um mich zu reden. So ständig, letzte Woche habe ich
einen Behinderten verletzt,
jetzt massiven Telefonbetrug.
Das ist jetzt so spannend, weil jetzt bist du so ein
Moralapostel mittlerweile geworden.
Wo denn? Auf jeden Fall.
Also, ich werde andauernd von dir angeflaunt,
weil ich mal wieder moralisch nicht
Vielen Dank. Das ist jetzt so spannend, weil jetzt bist du so ein Moralapostel mittlerweile geworden. Wo denn? Auf jeden Fall.
Also, ich werde andauernd von dir angeflaunt, weil ich mal wieder moralisch nicht richtig vorgegangen bin, weil ich mal in einem Meeting gelogen habe.
Dann kommt immer schon, von der Seite wird schon Ave Maria gebetet, damit ich nicht in die Hölle komme.
Und dann wird einem so böse Blicke zugeworfen, weil man mal moralisch nicht so ganz taktvoll vorgegangen ist.
Du bist mittlerweile ein sehr moralischer Typ, ich gar nicht. Ich bin ein Narziss. Ich habe aus meinen Sünden gelernt und ich bin weitergezogen. Geheilt. Ich bin weitergezogen. Und mit deinem Flyern da. Stefan. Ja, was denn? Wie schaut es aus? Die Leute schreiben schon immer weiter. Fit kann auch lustig. Wann geht es los? Ja, ein bisschen an dir ja auch mal wieder, an Wow, Florentin hat nämlich keine Zeit mehr abends, weil er den 18. Podcast gelauncht hat. Mittlerweile geht's um seine Podcasts nur noch, so wie so ein TV-Spielfilm für Podcasts. Gibt's das was eigentlich? Nein. Noch nicht, aber bald vielleicht. Aber das wäre echt mal eine Frage. Also ich würde gerne mal mit dir abends Badminton spielen gehen, weil ich brauche Sport. Also mittlerweile, ich bin auch in so einem Fitnesswahn durch dieses Jule, komme dann abends so energetisch nach Hause und denke mir, wow, jetzt vielleicht eine Runde joggen gehen, nope, Netflix sofort und dann gehe ich pennen. Ich würde gerne mal ein bisschen Sport machen. Ich habe auch gerade die Motivation, rauszugehen und Sport zu machen. Da hilft einem dieses dreckig schöne Wetter ja auch.
Ich fahre mit der Bahn nach Hause und irgendwann kommt die aus der Erde herausgeschossen und über die Rheinbrücke zu mir nach Deutz.
Und während man über die Rheinbrücke fährt, sieht man halt die Pollerwiesen.
Die Pollerwiesen sind Traum.
Einfach so grüne, große grüne Wiesen mit so einem leichten Kieselstrand direkt am Rhein. Wahnsinn. Blick auf den Dom, Blick auf die Kranhäuser. Toll. Und dann fahre ich mal nach Hause und es fahren die ganze Zeit einen glücklichen Menschen vorbei, die dann da liegen. Und ich genau weiß, wenn ich nicht zu Hause bin, jetzt bin ich einfach im Keller, bei mir in München, eine scheiß dreckige Kellerwohnung, mache die Rollladen zu, damit man mich nicht mehr masturbieren zu gucken kann und gucke Netflix. Das ist mein Leben. Ja. Und die haben da einfach coole coole zeit aber das ist mein mittwoch nächsten mittwoch spielen wir aber nicht so gern mit dem tauschen ja können wir gerne machen nächsten mittwoch erstes spiel periscope abonniert mal schon mal das youtube ufo vielleicht machen wir da youtube live youtube live oder sowas oder nehmen es nur auf youtube live ist nicht au kann man denn was aufnehmen und dann bei YouTube-Live einspeisen? Ja, das machen Rockbeams ja auch.
Ja, aber das glaube ich nicht so trivial. Aber wie machen die das denn?
Keine Ahnung, die haben ultra krasse Sendetechnik. Aber ich weiß nicht genau. Freut euch darauf, nächsten Mittwoch heißt es entweder Fit kann auch lustig und wir schwingen die Federballschläger.
Nächste Woche, denn da ist es Fett kann auch lustig, glaube ich, erst mal und dann irgendwann Fit.
Bis dahin wünschen wir euch natürlich eine fantastische Woche, macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, wir heben ab.
Tschüss.